uh okay so seven shots is out
um for you when you like look at a year
right let's say we we're January 2023 do
you automatically know what the year is
looking like like I'm gonna put this out
this out this out or you just kind of go
go with the flow in terms of like
release schedules like like it depends
on how much I've been working a year
prior you know I'm saying if I've been
working a year prior then yeah you know
what I'm saying like um
this year I didn't really have it
figured out last year I took a break
from uh
from the right hand side and focus more
on the producing an executive producing
side so I really ain't have I wasn't
really like just going to work like I
usually would do when I write you know
I'm saying I usually would go make a
record put it to the side go make
records put it to the side but I went
all that time without doing nothing
before seven shots yeah so I didn't
really know when I was gonna drop this
year I just woke up one day hit my
engineering was like yo let's lock in
and we went to the studio and I recorded
the whole album that day the whole album
that day because I recorded the whole
it's eight records yeah eight records
yeah I mean so one day yeah I recorded
the whole album that day that's [ __ ]
crazy you know what I'm saying yeah and
it was a field it was a feel like I like
to provide a feel so you know when I
that's how I record I like to capture
the energy of that time you know what
I'm saying and record everything while
I'm feeling that energy that's why the
project sound like that Sonic